OBSTACLES TO PASS THE
LEGISLATION GIVEN HER
UNWILLINGNESS TO CARVEOUT THE
FILIBUSTER.
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS ARE VOWING
TO PRESSURE TO PASS VOTING
RIGHTS PROTECTION TO HONOR KING.
>> Reporter: JANUARY 15th, 2022.
THE DAY MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR WOULD HAVE TURNED 93
YEARS OLD.
HIS ELDEST SON MARTIN LUTHER
KING III REFLECTS ON HOW HIS
FATHER WOULD FEEL TODAY.
DO YOU THINK HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
SURPRISED, DISCOURAGED THAT WE
ARE NOW MORE THAN 60 YEARS OUT
FROM HIS FIGHT FOR VOTING RIGHTS
THAT THERE IS STILL A FIGHT TO
BE HAD?
>> HE NEVER GAVE IN AND GAVE
OUT, BUT DISAPPOINTMENT YES,
HE'D BE GREATLY DISAPPOINTED AND
SAY THAT AMERICA MUST AND WILL
DO BETTER.
HE WOULD NEVER HAVE ACCEPTED
WHAT WE'RE GOING THROUGH AT THIS
POINT.
>> Reporter: KING HOPED BRINGING
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO GEORGIA THE
EPICENTER OF THE VOTING RIGHTS
BATTLE WOULD HAVE PUT ENOUGH
PRESSURE ON THE FEW DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS HOLDING UP VOTING
RIGHTS LEGISLATION TO RELENT.
>> PASS THE FREEDOM TO VOTE ACT.
>> Reporter: FOLLOWING BIDEN'S
FIERY ADDRESS, I SAT DOWN ON THE
FRONT PORCH OF THE HOME WHERE
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR WAS
BORN WITH HIS SON MARTIN III HIS
WIFE ANDREA AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE NATIONAL URBAN LEAGUE.
KING SHARED THE PRIVATE
CONVERSATION HE HAD WITH THE
PRESIDENT EARLIER THAT DAY.
WHAT DID YOU TELL HIM?
>> WE TALKED ABOUT LITERALLY THE
FULL FAITH OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE SAW YOU DO THAT WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE WANT TO SEE YOU DO THAT FOR
THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
>> I'VE BEEN HAVING THESE QUIET
CONVERSATIONS WITH MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS FOR THE LAST TWO
MONTHS.
I'M TIRED OF BEING QUIET.
>> Reporter: DO ANY OF YOU SHARE
THAT SENTIMENT?
TIRED OF THE PRESIDENT BEING
QUIET?
I MEAN, HE SAID HE WAS TIRED OF
BEING QUIET.
>> YES, WE'RE TIRED OF HIM BEING
QUIET AS HE'S TIRED OF BING
QUIET AND IT'S TIME TO ELEVATE
THIS BATTLE, ELEVATE THIS FIGHT
TO WHAT IT IS AND THAT'S A FIGHT
FOR THE FUTURE OF THIS NATION.
>> Reporter: 80-YEAR-OLD JESSE
JACKSON THAT MARCHED WITH KING
FOR CIVIL AND VOTING RIGHTS MORE
THAN A HALF CENTURY AGO ALSO
ATTENDED BIDEN'S SPEECH AND
BELIEVES THE ON GOING BATTLE FOR
THE BALLOT IS WORTH IT.
>> WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
FIGHT BACK TO SAVE THE COUNTRY
IS REALLY THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
>> Reporter: WHY ARE YOU SO
OPTIMISTIC?
>> MY BACK IS AGAINST THE WALL.
THERE IS NO FUTURE IN
HOPELESSNESS.
WE WILL KEEP HOPE ALIVE.
>> Reporter: KING WAS ENCOURAGED
BY BIDEN'S CALL TO LOWER THE
SENATE'S 60 VOTE THRESHOLD TO
GET NATIONAL VOTING RIGHTS
LEGISLATION PASSED BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, REALISTIC ABOUT HIS
CHANCES OF GETTING THE NECESSARY
APPROVAL.
>> I CAN'T SAY EVEN TODAY MY OWN
SELF-I'M CONFIDENT THAT IT WILL
PASS.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS IF
YOU CONTINUE DOWN THE PATHWAY
THAT IT FEELS LIKE WE'VE GONE
DOWN YOU'RE DEFINITELY DOOMED.
>> Reporter: TWO DAYS LATER BACK
IN WASHINGTON, KING'S FEARS
AFTER DEMOCRATIC SENATOR KYRSTEN
SINEMA ANNOUNCED SHE WOULDN'T
SUPPORT CHANGING THE FILIBUSTER
RULES.
KING SAID HISTORY WOULD REMEMBER
SINEMA UNKINDLY AND HER HOME
STATE COULD PAY.
>> ARIZONA WAS ONE OF THE LAST
STATES TO PASS THE KING HOLIDAY
BILL AND ONE THING THAT HAPPENED
IS THE SUPER BOWL WAS REMOVED.
>> Reporter: SATURDAY THE KING
FAMILY WILL MARK KING'S BIRTHDAY
IN ARIZONA TO KEEP UP THE
PRESSURE ON VOTING RIGHTS AND ON
MONDAY, THE MLK DAY HOLIDAY,
THEIR FIGHT IS IN THE NATION'S
CAPITAL WHERE THEY'RE ASKING
AMERICANS ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO
HONOR KING BY PROMOTING VOTING
RIGHTS AND LEGISLATION.
>> ALL HEIRS TO WHAT HE STOOD
AND FOUGHT AND DIED FOR AND I
THINK WHAT WE'RE SIMPLY SAYI